hey everyone how's the guy gets disdain
and today we're going to be unboxing the
PlayStation VR and as you can see over
here it seems to me that this box has
already been unboxed sort of yesterday
was the first ever YouTube gaming live
show on the show I unbox this but of
course it's a live show so I didn't
actually get to unbox everything so I
kind of just dug right into it and
ripped everything to shreds and I don't
really think I even got just the
anything that was in the box well now
we're gonna head on over to Justine
because it is time for the first ever
unboxing of the PlayStation VR I'm
extremely excited I've actually never
done a live and boxing before so this is
this is a first
have you ever let her in here with a
knife yeah I brought seven knives
actually this is the one that made the
cut so let's just open this up since we
need to really get in here let's see
what's happening this has everything all
right do you wanna help uh well I'll
just watch you get you can handle all
the guards yeah I'll be the garbage man
okay and the bubble wrap Thanks alright
man look at this this mic is so sharp so
we got the box here let's see okay can
you guys see you ready see alright you
wanted this real quick
uh yeah probably safer with me anyways
do you want to help me you just said he
said it was your unboxing you're
assisting though yeah this comes out in
a couple weeks October 13th so this is a
first look oh it's incredible oh that's
actually cool the box like the hook this
is some great packaging yeah real nice
we get one of these don't break anything
cables okay when you're doing about to
do unbox every cable - I do we probably
have time for that she's there I was
like I'm doing all the folder here's
some more cable yeah let's just get into
the headset we're trying to get in as
the girl
so III I did get a chance to play the
Resident Evil demo which is really
really good and you play a Batman one
yeah I play Batman that's amazing
it was great er react we for a pretty
long time just gonna throw it on what do
you want me to do so this is kind of
like your splitter so like you'll have
an HDMI going in and we're going out to
the TV okay and you set this up next to
your PlayStation uh-huh and you'll have
the camera at either the top receiver
below right we got to try it at e3 very
briefly and it was a lot of fun
the Batman was a really really great
experience now that's awesome cuz it's
like we you know the thing with VRS are
a lot of stuff that like sort of these
speculative like sort of you know early
access games and like PlayStation VR
does have Batman Arkham vr which is
amazing and then also they're doing a
Star Wars rogue one x-wing thing that's
coming out in December for PSV r2 which
is going to be really cool you're gonna
have Star Wars on yeah er yeah where
were you three that's cool
so because of it alive show I couldn't
actually really unbox it like I normally
would I was throwing things everywhere
and I didn't really get to see what was
actually inside of the box
other than the PS VR headset you guys
want to watch the full YouTube gaming
live show I'll put a link in the
description and every Thursday for the
next seven weeks there will be a live
show every Thursday I'll be on for a few
weeks they'll be other tons of fun
creators and lots of fun other things
that I don't really know what's gonna
happen but that's the fun of live so
inside this box is a partially unbox PSP
oh we've got a lot of bubble wrap
oh god I was pull over I don't even like
this camera can see what's happening in
here there's a lot of bubble wrap I just
gotta get everything out of this box is
what's really gonna happen god
okay Oh ps4 system a PlayStation camera
both sold separately or acquired I don't
actually have a PlayStation camera so
I'm gonna have to get that
so this nasty three I got a chance to do
the Resident Evil demo I played it for a
really long time and that game freaked
me out because it is so immersive and
you're sort of just moving around I mean
I'm sure some of you guys to play VR for
those of you guys who haven't it's
pretty real my first initial thoughts
for PlayStation VR because it is the
console VR and you don't need a PC to do
it the barrier to entry is super simple
granted if you've used a computer you
could redirections it's not that
difficult to setup VR on your PC but a
lot of people don't have pcs that are we
already so with this this is making VR
accessible to anyone with a console so
inside the box was all of this stuff but
I liked about this box is how they had
it open like this it was sort of a nice
experience opening up the box which I
did not really get to fully enjoy
because I was so concerned about how
much time I had on the live show when I
was nervous that I'd go over the time or
under the time it's very hard if you've
never done a live show before it's a not
as easy as it looks
so here we have maybe our headset this
is a great box though I was
a great box to throw on the ground
here's the headset and inside here we've
got these little things were going to
take off take it off now also comes with
some headphones our headphones so this
here looks like what is basically going
to be powering the headset so it looks
like right here is where you connect
your ps4 and this is where you connect
the HDMI out to your TV and over here
this little section is where you connect
the headset I like this little slider
thing looks like everything is very
nicely labeled and numbered this looks
to be the power brick to power this
here's our first HDMI cable labeled a
number one number two a USB to micro USB
cable PlayStation VR cleaning cloth so
the reason I haven't done very many VR
demos is because I want it to be my own
a headset I don't like putting on a
headset after somebody else's put on a
headset even going to my friends house
and playing their VR headsets I'm like
you know what I'm okay I'll wait for my
own I wouldn't say I'm a germaphobe but
like in a little bit of a germaphobe
like I don't want strangers faces on my
face unless I do want your face on my
face
oh yeah PlayStation VR little cleansing
cloth elbow came with a set of extra
earbuds here to put on your headphones
this is number four yeah this is just an
extender so that you'll be able to
actually move around using your headset
oh look at this
I was wondering what games I was gonna
play because I didn't have anything
currently downloaded and this doesn't
come out for another two weeks so
problem solved
Oh God gal we've got everything on box
let's go through and see exactly what's
in here since I didn't really get a
chance to go through every little piece
of detail number one we've got our HDMI
cable
number two USB cable three AC adapter
not labeled but this is our AC adapter
power cable number four this is the VR
headset extension cable so you can
actually move around and not be stuck
Lea to your PlayStation sitting down and
number five is clearly the headset so
here you go then I pre-ordered this
thing the second that you could get it
so on the instructions are calling this
the processor unit sounds really fancy
I'm gonna call this the magical box of
making things happen so this is cool
slide it up this is where you plug in
the headset slide it back down this is
where you plug in your ps4 and this is
your HDMI out to your TV and this is the
USB cable which smoke I just plugs in
right there it's pretty light all things
considered and at e3 when I played one
of the demos I probably played for about
45 minutes all right look what we got
here so setting up your VR so in our
directions it looks like they're making
things pretty simple I'll play your
PlayStation from the TV and then put it
into the processor unit which is this
plug in your PlayStation camera easy
enough HDMI out from your PlayStation 2
the processor unit these are great
directions USB out from the front of
your PlayStation 2 the processor unit
then you gotta plug it in and then it
goes through telling you how to put in
the headset I mean it's honestly so
straightforward that if you can't follow
this then
probably shouldn't have the headset
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this quick
unboxing I will do a setup video later
but for the time being I'm gonna go edit
this so that I can get this up for you
guys today
I'm extremely excited for VR because it
really is such a fun and immersive way
to play video games watch content and
I'm excited to start creating content in
360 so it's going to be really fun to
see where this all goes know what you
guys think liminal games you're looking
forward to and I will see you in the
next video bye on what I think of my
iPhone 7 plus if you guys are new and
have no idea I ended up getting the jet
black one I have a bunch of videos where
I talked about the issues and everything
that I had with actually getting it but
it's here it's in my hands I also got a
lot of really great comments on the fake
unboxing that I did which was
technically a better unboxing than the
actual unboxing was like